So,
um,
in the past I've done some work with big
brother,
big sister and whatever.
Um,
that being said that the most common
story I tend to hear from 50 youth is
that they're raised in a single family
home,
usually with a mom,
daddy's there on the picture and
alcoholic,
whatever,
whatever they brought her.
So we have this child who is trying to
seek ways to make himself healthy and
empower himself in ways that a healthy
father should have done.
So,
you know,
between the formative years of like one
to four.
So I think,
you know,
I'm going with this,
um,
how,
let's say for someone who born without
like a good father figure,
where would they go out in the world and
like what four spheres of influence
where they try to expose themselves to,
to like gain access to that Fountain of
Health and knowledge at a father or a
good father figure should have provide
them to in the first place.
Okay.
Well,
partly,
I mean certainly to some degree a good
mother can provide that to some degree,
although it's hard for one person to be
everything right.
You know?
And I think one of the conundrums that
face women,
and this is a tough one,
and this is why I think women are higher
end trade agreeableness and higher in
trait negative emotion,
is that the primary problem that a woman
has with an infant is why not throw it
out a window because it's very annoying.
I mean it's there all the time.
It's constant demand.
It's absolutely constantly man,
tremendous dependency.
And so a woman has to be tilted towards
mercy.
That's how it looks to me like.
And especially during.
It's so important during the.
Especially the first year when children
are so unbelievably vulnerable.
And so I think it's very difficult for
women to be merciful like that and to
make the shift to encouraging
disciplinary.
I think that's a very difficult thing
for people to do simultaneously.
Although you know,
people,
people.
I'm not saying that women are always
only merciful and men are always only
encouraging disciplinarians,
but things do sort themselves out to
some degree like that.
And I think also the biochemical
transformations that accompany pregnancy
and childbirth and lactation also killed
a mother towards that as well because he
has to really love that little thing.
Right?
It's,
it's number one,
no matter what it demands and then
telling it what to do and making sure
it's behaving properly.
That's,
that's a whole different issue now.
But the kids who lack fathers,
I mean,
first of all,
they can find that to some degree in
their friends and that's often what
father this boys do in particular.
They,
they,
they go into gangs and they generate the
missing men masculinity and the game.
Well that's not so good because like
what the hell do they know that?
Well,
they don't know anything,
right?
They're just stupid kids and they're
like 15 years old and their testosterone
is pumping and they're trying to get the
hell away from their mother,
which is what they're supposed to do.
And they're not in the right position to
exercise authority over themselves.
So that's not good.
They can find it in education,
they can find it in books,
they can find it.
Movies,
they can find it in sports heroes and so
forth because the image of the father is
fragmented and distributed among the
community,
but it's very,
very difficult to not have a father and
you know,
one of the things that we're doing in
our society,
which I think is.
I think it's absolutely is that we're
making the case that all families are
equal.
It's like,
sorry,
no wrong.
There's no empirical data supporting
that proposition.
By the way.
It's much better for kids to have two
parents who those parents are.
That's a whole different issue,
but if I could just one more thing.
Oh,
how would you ask that question too?
Let's see.
A daughter who was raised by a father
because she would obviously have
different ways of find those fragments
of her missing father then like a boy
would instead because obviously they're
raised differently or at least they
should have been.
Well,
I think it's the same issue,
you know?
I mean,
I think.
I think that another danger that
emerges,
Mrs [inaudible] of course famous
observation is that you know,
if there's mom and child or father and
child,
that relationship can get a little
closer than it should and then the lines
get blurry and mixed and I'm not saying
that that happens to everyone obviously,
but,
but it's still a danger that that's
inherent in the situation.
They're were thrust together too tightly
without sufficient resources and so the
responsibility has to be distributed
more and like I really do think that
it's the sign of the degeneration of the
society when the,
when,
when single parenthood becomes anything
approximating the norm,
it's not a good idea.
Then the.
I'm part of the reason I believe that
and I think this has to do with the
overwhelming selfishness of,
of,
of modern life is that marriage isn't
for the people who were married.
It's for the children obviously,
and like if you can't handle that,
grow the hell up Sarah.
I mean,
seriously.
Yeah.
Seriously.
Once you,
once you have kids,
yes.
It is not about you,
period.
Now,
that doesn't mean it isn't about you at
all,
but it just seems so self evident to me.
I can't believe that anybody would even
would even question it.
Oh,
let's.
Oh yes.
Well,
I'm certainly aware of that.
Yes.
It's questioned.
It's almost illegal to question it now,
you know,
to,
to or illegal to make the set of
propositions that I make,
so that's the best I can do.
That's excellent.
Thank you.